el pasto sanitario entró en vigor este
lunes pero para los empleados de este
café que ya lo habían implementado aún
hay confusión tengo que revisar a los
que están sentados allí pero no a los de
allá realmente no comprendo otros sin
embargo ya están a bordo
como pueden ver solo toma tres segundos
escanear a alain así que no es grave de
pagos o de pagos o algo y esto asegura
que sólo gente vacunada entre al
restaurante sea tengo para esto un
código qr puede ser obtenido tras
complementar un esquema de vacunación o
dando negativa a un test de kobe en las
últimas 72 horas ahora también es
necesario para abordar un vuelo o un bus
o un tren de larga distancia este
conductor está listo para las objeciones
de los pasajeros
simplemente les diré pues entonces no
subes porque aquí yo soy la persona
responsable pública hasta ahora sólo los
cines con más de 50 personas requerían
el pase sanitario pero ahora salas más
pequeñas pasan a estar incluidas en el
esquema es como noches y para después el
ex estamos esperando ver cómo
reaccionará la gente sabemos con certeza
que veremos una caída
cifras pero simplemente estamos felices
de abrir nuevamente
el aparte de emergencias a aquellos que
visiten a seres queridos enfermos en el
hospital o lleguen para una cita tendrán
que mostrar su código
he estado vacunado desde hace un tiempo
y tenemos que proteger a todos es
demasiado fuera hay que respetar las
reglas pero puedo ver por qué le
causaría problemas a las personas que
están en contra de las vacunas o bien la
medida también queda vigente para
centros comerciales pero les
corresponderá a los consejeros locales
determinar cuáles de ellos quedan
cubiertos por la normativa